Professor Zhang
Changping's
Close Reading
Professor Zhang Changping
Department of Archeaology, Wuhan University
Visiting Scholar, Harvard University
For this particular ding, as you can see the two handles and two feet are parallel.
This means it is the front side of the tripod.
For an object like this, from the front we can see a complete pattern.
More importantly, the place where the rear foot meets the body of the bronze
often will have an inscription.
Thus, a round vessel will often still have a front and back side.
This particular ding has an inscription on it.
Many scholars believe that inscriptions from the Shang-Zhou period are clan insignia.
From a decorative perspective, we can see that the patterns on this ding
have undergone nearly a thousand years of development.
Thus its ornamentations appear extremely sophisticated and delicate.
In fact, we can see different levels of ornamentation.
At first glance, we can see that this ding looks like an animal mask.
We can see that it appears to be in the form of a beast.
For example we can see its horns, its ears, etc. created through mid-relief
We can see that on the mid-relief there are very delicate patterns.
There are also many delicate patterns on the background.
In terms of ornamentation, there are background patterns,
there are mid-relief patterns, and there are patterns on the mid-relief.
Thus it has three different layers of patterns.
This reflects the creator's drive to push the decorative potential to the extreme.